much is constantly happening that annoys
us
trains pull out of platforms as we
approach them
taps snap off their moorings
shopping bags leak suppliers go bankrupt
colleagues resign
cars break down
it is all undoubtedly maddening
but the question is how much does it all
beneath the surface have to feel
intentional as well
for a certain kind of personality it is
very hard to hold on to the idea that
many troubles might come down to
something as innocent as chance
it simply seems implausible that awful
things might repeatedly unfold at
terribly inopportune moments without
some kind of malevolent intent being
involved
it can't be just an accident that the
dinner order went missing that the
cinema seat was double booked
that the phone's battery has died
why did their dry cleaning and no one
else's end up being stolen and their new
shoes spring a leak
why is there a strange smell just next
to where they are seated on the plane
how come there is a small beetle in
their salad
it's as though someone is trailing them
undermining them
laying traps for them
and laughing at them
it seems like there is some kind of
conspiracy to make them look like a
[ __ ] to the world why else have they
been walking around all day with a
sticker on the back of their coat
and why does their zip jam exactly 10
minutes before an important dinner
no wonder they may get very cross indeed
the sad and touching truth is that there
is of course
almost never any conspiracy at play
but that it strongly feels like there is
one on the inside tells us a lot about
the origins of paranoiac
hypersensitivity
it is the bitter fruit of self-hatred
when we heartily dislike ourselves it is
only natural to have the impression that
the world is ridiculing us in turn
the hotel concierge knows exactly how
awful we are
that's why they've given us the room
with the malfunctioning air conditioning
unit
the waiter has deep experience of our
revoltingness
that's why they chose our trousers on
which to drop a piece of butter
the phone company knows that we are an
idiot and that we think dreadful things
that's why they've made sure our mobile
would give out on the second day of our
trip
we need to be given the chance to see
that our suspicious natures are a
symptom of a self-hatred that owes its
origins not to the prevalence of actual
plots and schemes but to childhood
dynamics
in which we lacked the reassurance
attention and care we deserved and for
this we deserve immense ongoing
sympathy
the world doesn't hate us
we have just learned to have contempt
for ourselves which returns to haunt us
in the form of imagined plots
no one is actually laughing at us
we weren't loved properly
and now don't like ourselves very much
that's the true outrage for which we
should reserve our anger
and our self-compassion
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more